I want to preface this I'm not drawing
any conclusions okay
I'm just making an observation
and the observation is that just weeks
before the massive vinyl chloride leak
and burn off that is currently poisoning
East Palestine Ohio and likely
compromising the air and water across a
much larger geographic region
the CDC changed its toxicology report on
vinyl chloride and its FAQ page
for the first time in 17 years
before possibly as little as 11 days
before but certainly it happened at some
point in the month before this this
accident so I've got here the
the toxicology report the FAQs from from
and here you just see a lot more
information in the 2006 one
How likely is vinyl chloride to cause
cancer you see a lot of specific
information about an increased risk of
liver brain lung cancer cancers of the
blood how can Vinyl chloride affect
children there's a whole paragraph about
that
has the federal government made
recommendations to protect human health
yes as the EPA requires that the amount
of vinyl chloride in drinking water not
exceeds 0.002 milligrams per liter of
water talks about how much in terms of
parts per million Can it can be in the
workplace it's pretty thorough and then
you go to the
the FAQ on vinyl chloride that just
dropped last month that the section on
how to protect children is totally gone
the section on cancer is a much
simplified that there's a lot less
detail the the section about how many
parts per million or milligrams per
liter that's all gone
so it's just a little this was January
this is just the what are what are the
odds all I'm saying is just the odds are
kind of
it's kind of weird and it isn't nearly
as weird as the fact that the whole
incident the whole train derailment
chemical spilling poisoned the town
incident was depicted in a movie that
came out last year was six eight months
ago called White Noise which was not
only filmed in the area in which the
actual incident would occur but even
included people from East Palestine as
extras in the movie One such extra an
East Palestine resident named Ben Ratner
has told reporters quote the first half
of the movie is all almost exactly
what's going on here
and I'm not making any accusations I'm
actually not okay I'm not coming to any
conclusions
even though the CDC and the public
authorities more broadly have completely
squandered their credibility in
particular over the last few years and
have lied to us on several occasions
you know I am not a conspiracy theorist
I'm really not
but I am a coincidence noticer
and it's weird
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Henry Biermann
who says Happy Valentine's Day from Dr
fauci you make my heart stop
it's not shouldn't be funny I guess you
either have to laugh or cry don't you
when you want to express your feelings
about your friends to your friends you
gotta check out pure talk right now head
on over to puretalk.com use promo code
Knowles let me ask you something do you
love being locked into a multi-year
phone contract with huge penalties
probably not nobody does pure talk is
the antidote to woke wireless companies
they're the only Wireless company that
offers a 100 money back guarantee so
they are so sure that you're going to
love their service that if you don't
they will give you your money back stop
paying for Verizon ATT T-Mobile cut your
bill in half do not sacrifice any
coverage with pure talk they're us-based
customer service team makes the switch
super easy the us-based customer service
team is as far as I'm concerned is worth
the switch in and of itself you can also
switch in as little as 10 minutes while
keeping your phone and your phone number
your first month is guaranteed risk free
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles kwles to save 50 off your first
month that is puretalk.com promo code
Knowles Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
I think I'm going to use that just came
to me when I was thinking about these
stories the White Noise movie The
toxicology report the FAQ from the CDC
I'm really not a conspiracy theorist I
always look for the least complex answer
for any sort of odd phenomenon
but I definitely am a coincidence
noticer and it doesn't necessarily mean
that there is some secret shadowy group
of people that are doing all sorts of
Nefarious things at the very least
though there is no such thing as
coincidences you know modern Libs
believe that every
strange and no matter how big the
miracle is no matter how in your face
some kind of Miracle is they'll say oh
it's just random chance for Christians
though for people who are traditionally
religious there's no such thing as
coincidences because there's Providence
and there's an order to the universe now
what's going on in this case in this
really bizarre
incident in East Palestine Ohio
is that just the broad order of the
universe is that just random chance or
something else I don't know I do know
that it's also really weird how the
authorities are downplaying this
incident had this been
a few weeks ago had you told me there's
going to be an environmental disaster
that happens
anywhere anywhere in the West
what's going to happen afterward I would
have said well you're going to get all
The Usual Suspects there John Kerry is
going to fly in and demand environmental
cleanup Saint Greta Saint Greta of the
Blessed sailboat she's going to come in
she's going to say how dare you trains
derail how there would be big protests
massive press conferences
none of that none of that has happened
you had no environmentalists have shown
up to protest
the authorities haven't shown up there's
no Joe Biden demanding stricter
environmental regulations his signature
legislative accomplishment last year was
passing a green bill right the climate
change bill which he initially told us
was an inflation reduction act but then
admitted almost immediately after it
passed now this is just about the
environment okay you care so much about
the environment where are you in East
Palestine how come nobody's talking
about this how come everyone wants to
play this down the the transportation
secretary Pete butterjudge took a little
break from his paternity leave his
Perpetual paternity leave to go on
television now what two weeks after the
incident and he went on television to
downplay the significance of the
derailment
look Rail City something that uh that
has evolved a lot over the years but
there's clearly more that needs to be
done because while this uh horrible
situation has gotten a particularly high
amount of attention there are roughly 1
000 cases a year of a train derailing
so it's no big deal actually guys I know
that uh there is this major derailment
where uh the all the water and and the
air around this this area has been
poisoned and I know that actually about
10 percent of the country gets its
drinking water from uh roughly around
this region but hey there's a lot of
derailments every year it's really not
it's not a big deal Move Along Move
Along these are not the droids you're
looking for uh-huh
ah it seems like a big deal to me
and it seems like a big deal that the
authorities are saying this is not a big
deal that's really weird
maybe it's that Pete Buddha judge is
just trying to cya it could be maybe he
feels that he's totally exposed here and
he's a flop of a transportation
secretary a job that is essentially a
no-show job it's one of the least
important least notable jobs in the
government
Pete Buda judge got it as the Chinese
pointed out in their correct propaganda
yesterday he got it as a kind of vanity
political appointment to appease some of
the left-wing base and to check off some
politically correct boxes
but
you got to do something right and where
are the other people
Senator J.D Vance new senator from Ohio
he's calling BS on the elected officials
and the EPA the EPA which is saying oh
no the water is totally safe to drink
this kind of thing happens all the time
Move Along move along well JD has a
challenge for the EPA administrator
you know it reminds me of that scene in
Aaron Brockovich where she puts the
water in front of him and says if you
think it's clean we brought this water
from uh you know the the community that
was affected uh look I I think that it's
the EP administrator wants to stand here
and tell people that the tap water is
safe by all means they should be willing
to drink it are you
uh no I just sold I told Tom I think
that uh if I was living here I would
drink the bottled water for now better
safe than sorry especially since it's
being provided for free that's the
guidance I would give it again you know
residents are going to make their own
decisions on this but my honest personal
advice is I'd be drinking the bottled
water right now
I love the reporter's question maybe he
meant it in an innocent way or maybe it
was sort of a gotcha where JD van says
look if you really think this is all
fine EPA administrator come down here
right now and drink the water he says
well will you drink the water and JD
looks a little bit confused almost he
says
um no did you not hear what no I
wouldn't drink the water I think it's
poison and I I would drink the bottled
water especially when it's being
provided for free I don't believe the
EPA administrator and I doubt that the
EPA administrator believes the EPA
administrator
does anybody seriously believe after
what a million gallons of of this or a
million pounds I sort of forget whatever
the measurement is of of this Vinyl
chloride to say nothing of the other
toxic chemicals that leaked at then were
set on fire turning to phosgene and
sulfuric or hydrochloric acid rather and
possibly sulfuric acid but certainly
hydrochloric acid you think that
two weeks after that the water is fine
the air is fine nobody believes that in
fact there's a resident of East
Palestine who just went out to show you
on video how not fine the water is so
this resident goes out to a little Creek
in the woods she gets a
little piece of wood and throws it into
the water so the water looks fine at
first but then the minute she disrupts
the water
with the wood then you see all the
chemicals bubble to the top
there's rainbow colors everywhere
you look down it's like
it's an oil slick
is it worse than an oil slick though
it's much more poisonous than an oil
slick
so it might it might look fine if you're
if you're an EPA administrator you're
going in you're testing the water and
you're just testing the water on top
maybe it looks fine maybe the point that
she's making is all the poison was down
there at the bottom so you throw a rock
in you throw a log in then all that
those chemicals rise up to the top
so sure we can all trust that the water
is safe in in East Palestine Ohio the
minute that Joe Biden or
the EPA administrator or Pete bootage
Edge or whoever go and drink it but none
of them are going to do that this
reminds me of in Indian elections
candidates who are running for office in
India will often go to Varanasi this
this holy city considered very holy in
India and that's where the Ganges is and
they'll go and they'll either wash
themselves in the water from the Ganges
they'll maybe they'll jump into the
water from the Ganges sometimes they'll
even drink some of the water from the
Ganges which is horrifying because
that's the river where people throw dead
bodies bodies that have been burnt on
along the side of the river or in some
cases even with human flesh on it and so
it's just teeming with bacteria and then
what happens the people get sick
well okay I give the politicians some
credit actually in their own religious
tradition they're willing to subject
themselves to that okay
leftist government administrators drink
that water in East Palestine drink that
water in East Palestine which could
affect water threat a lot of the country
drink that make us all feel better until
they do I ain't buying it
speaking of stuff in the water
speaking of things in the water turning
the freaking frogs gay and
maybe turning other people into other
other things
the craning company guys broke this
story a couple of days ago I meant to
get to it yesterday fortunately we're
able to get to it today
the story is from this interview with
one of Leah Thomas's teammates Leah
Thomas is actually named will Thomas
he's that hulking dude who swam on the
UPenn women's swim team and then beat
all the girls and took their trophies
and he's just obviously a big guy but he
pretends to be a woman and so we've all
got to pretend that he's a girl and he's
smashing the glass ceiling and it's so
wonderful and brave and stunning
so one of will Thomas's teammates comes
out and gives a great interview which I
strongly recommend you go check out at
cranny company
where she says man this is gross this
guy showed up to the locker room he
strips down naked all of us girls had to
be subjected to looking at him back when
he still had the male parts
and then she spilled a little bit more
tea
the part that everyone is focusing on
from this interview is that uh will
Thomas's boyfriend it's a boy who thinks
that he's a girl I don't know
will Thomas's paramour uh was
photographed holding up a a jar with
what appeared to be pickle juice and
then two spherical objects in
the the jar
so at two I don't think they were olives
I don't think they were little onions
that you put in the cocktails okay
so
that was what everyone was focusing on
in this interview with with one of
Will's competitors I misspoke not one of
his teammates one of his competitors
and uh there's something more
interesting about the interview though
and the pictures that were uncovered and
the details about will Thomas's personal
life
there's a bunch of weird satanic stuff
there's a bunch of really weird sexual
stuff that was if not posted by Will
Thomas at least liked by Will Thomas on
Instagram things that talked about Auto
gynophilia auto gynophilia is one of the
explanations for transgenderism there
there are within I was going to say
historically but because the whole
phenomenon is so modern
there have been proposed in recent
decades two types of transgenderism
homosexual men who view themselves as
women and also men who are sexually
aroused by the thought of them having
female genitals that's called auto gun
afilia
so will Thomas seems to have liked
some of these posts about Auto
gynophilia which might suggest that
will Thomas will Thomas's identity is
a little weirder
is is a little more sexual in nature but
then what I find even more interesting
than that is
all the weird satanic imagery so
one post liked by Will Thomas
jokes that will will bring about the
quote collapse of Western Civilization
another one is a picture of Will as a
demonic dominatrix character
uh there are posts that refer to will
Thomas as being in a follicle that's a
group of sexually confused people who
all do weird stuff with one another
uh in fact the person who wrote nice
follicule is a is a user named crybaby
hell
uh
Beyond uh crybaby hell there's
another uh transgender identifying
person who has photos in a very
sexualized abusive kind of fetishistic
way
uh the Gory and stunning as one
commenter writes and so I'm not making
any particular
claims about will Thomas or any of will
Thomas's friends or
friends with benefits or more than
friends
I just can't help but notice something
that I've noticed for a long time
it's always the same imagery
it's always it always gets back to weird
devil demonic horns and Tails and
pitchforks kind of imagery I made this
point at the Grammys when Sam Smith got
on stage dressed like a lesbian Lucifer
and jiggled around with a bunch of
androgynous transsexual looking people
and the the clip ended up going viral
because my publicists over at Media
Matters were very shocked and offended
that I made the point that very often
depictions of the Demonic are quite
androgynous or trans and depictions of
transgenderism and androgyny are quite
often demonic
which is just true
so when Media Matters posted and I just
retweeted it I thought yeah that's very
true what a great point I made
it's always this kind of imagery isn't
it isn't that a little bit
odd
isn't that a little bit weird it's
almost as though
you can't really separate the physical
from the metaphysical it's almost as
though symbols matter and so the reason
that that people with these weird sexual
desires keep going back to the same
symbolism the same symbols that we've
seen all the way back to Antiquity with
the bad guy the little bad Red Demon
with the horns and the Pitchfork and the
tail and the fangs and the goatee and
whatever all of these symbols is because
they might actually represent something
why do we talk about people who struggle
with these kinds of psychological
problems as having demons
today we think that we're just speaking
metaphorically oh it's just a metaphor
it's it's a metaphor for chemicals going
off in their brains
well I don't even know what that means I
mean if we're talking about metaphor
we're talking about something beyond the
physical world but all of us I don't
care how hardened a materialist you are
you behave as though there is something
beyond the material world you believe
you behave as though there is some kind
of moral order you behave as though
there are things that are immaterial
that still matter like loves and joys
and Mathematics and out of all the
intangible things that you can't quite
touch or smell or see but nevertheless
you know are there and you know those
things are often represented by physical
objects
we all behave that way and so I just
think we need to pay a little more
attention to symbols I mentioned at the
top of the show that I'm not a
conspiracy theorist at all I'm actually
rather grounded and always seek a
rational explanation when when one is
available to me but I also can't help
but notice things and I find that's
especially true when we're talking about
symbols
the modern world refuses to acknowledge
symbols in fact it explicitly denies
symbolism because it in its thought if
not in its Behavior it tries to deny
that there's any metaphysical reality
beneath the physical world
but for Christians or Jews or Muslims or
or even pagans or anybody with any even
quasi-traditional understanding of
religion and man's place in the universe
there is no such thing really as
coincidence
there is a broader Providence there is
there is meaning okay so if you believe
that there is meaning
then there has got to be meaning to the
fact that all these sexual deviants
keep going back to the same image of
that same old devil gotta mean
something you know who loves talking
about signs and symbols and meaning
and psychology our friend Dr Jordan
Peterson and I'm very excited to
announce that we have a new five-part
series with Jordan available at
dailywear plus here is a first look at
the trailer
what you already know is not sufficient
to guide you into the future
[Applause]
is indeterminate you cannot compute your
way through the present into the future
you need to use your vision
to weave your way through life
you're going to face tyrants and you're
going to face mogs is there a vision
that can sustain you in the face of that
you should accept yourself just the way
you are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
that sounded so persuasive that I am
going to start doing this show in a
Canadian accent
tomorrow you're going to see me get on
the show and I'm going to say I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show Buckaroo no I can't pull it
off but Jordan can He's Got Fabulous
advice in this series that can really
help you improve your life episode one
is available now new episodes are coming
online every week but it's all exclusive
for daily wire Plus members if you're
not a member now is a great time to join
get 40 off right now on an annual
membership you will unlock over 55-0
hours of exclusive Jordan content along
with our entire library of movies docs
specials
kids content
all coming this spring and our first
major scripted series coming later this
year we've also got some exciting new
exclusive content in the works for this
year that we can't tell you about yet
you don't want to miss it if you needed
some inspiration and help building a
compelling vision for your life
join now at dailywire.com subscribe to
watch vision and Destiny
speaking of demons
really troubling report from the CDC
speaking of the CDC too it's all kind of
looping back today isn't it very
coincidental according to a new CDC
study 57 of high school girls reported
feelings of sadness or hopelessness in
that is a 58 increase from 2011.
30 percent
seriously considered suicide
that is a 60 almost increase from 2011.
24 made plans for suicide
that is a 60 increase from 2011.
42 percent of high school students
overall felt persistent sadness or
hopelessness
22 percent seriously considered suicide
18 percent made a plan for suicide
10 percent
attempted suicide
you might be tempted to say
well this is a problem from kovid
because covid up into the world lock
students at home and that's that's why
this happened the trend long predates
covet it's not as I was 2011 and then to
do is going along fine and then there
goes covet now it spikes and then it'll
go back to normal now this has been a
trend for a long time
and 50 million Frenchmen can't be wrong
by which I mean
there is something structural here
Beyond just the personal problems or
personal quirks of these students who
are engaging in this there is a
structural social problem that is
impelling people to do this
and we don't want to acknowledge any of
it I don't think it's very complicated
I think that
when you have a national policy
that
incentivizes the destruction of the
family
the entire world for young people
that's probably going to make them
pretty sad that's going to make them
feel pretty hopeless when you have an
educational apparatus that denies
subjective truth that's probably going
to make people pretty sad and pretty
anxious
pretty hopeless when you have an
educational apparatus again that
encourages Vice and discourages and
mocks virtue that's going to make people
pretty sad and pretty hopeless I suspect
when you have a national policy that
discourages religion don't forget this
isn't just the culture and you know
politics is just Downstream of the
culture it's a national policy that bans
the Bible from schools
and that prescribes weird gay porn in
schools that's a national policy that's
probably going to make kids pretty sad
and pretty hopeless
when you have a national policy that
encourages kids to deny their true
identity and to embrace deviant and
false and delusional identities
National policy from the federal
government saying hey kids
hey hey boys you're not really boys
you're a girl you need to you need to
pump yourself full of all sorts of
hormones
you need to chop off your body parts
you need to engage in very destructive
behavior and your parents don't
understand you uh Big Daddy Biden I
understand you
I oh yeah me Richard Levine the very
confused ghoulish assistant Secretary of
Health oh yeah I understand you you just
need to go on a bunch of drugs and deny
who you really are don't talk to your
parents oh don't your parents are awful
they're evil they don't really get you I
get you that's probably going to make
people feel pretty pretty hopeless
and when you have a pervasive
National policy of denying
religion
which means denying hope
people are probably going to be hopeless
that's a national policy because of a
novel and
wrong interpretation of the First
Amendment which says that there will be
no established religion at the federal
level which has been misinterpreted
against all of American history and
against right reason to say that the
state has to be functionally atheist
it's a very new idea
we still have blasphemy laws in some
states because this the states haven't
caught up to this new and wrong idea
which purports to speak for the American
project and the American experiment
that's going to make people feel
hopeless
if you really believe
that there is no meaning to anything
that there is no hope that you're going
to just
walk around as a kind of a cosmic
accident you're nothing more than me
you're nothing more than flesh you
should live for nothing more than your
own pleasure and then you're going to
take a dirt nap and turn to worm food
you are going to be pretty depressed
to say nothing of the economic factors
to say nothing of the job prospects
don't look as good for young people
right now to say nothing of the economy
is not looking as good for young people
to say nothing of uh the prospect of war
is higher now than it was 20 years ago
that's what everyone else is going to
focus on I think that is actually part
and parcel of the same problem that the
same materialist lie
that that Barack Obama peddled when he
said well we need to go into different
countries in the Middle East because we
need to give them iPhones yep if we just
give people a little bit more money and
some iPhones then they they won't want
to
perpetrate Jihad then they'll be
peaceful as if to say that man is just
purely an economical being and all we
care about is acquiring more stuff that
is not true that doesn't motivate people
money will not ultimately make you happy
we used to know this this was really
basic stuff in our culture and now not
even the conservatives half the time
believe that
is it any wonder that people are
depressed is it any wonder that people
are suicidal
absolutely
predictable that's what we're seeing
before we go speaking of depression poor
Senator John fetterman has just checked
himself into Walter Reed for depression
you know he was in a hospital he was GW
Medical Center a week or two ago and
people were wondering is this another
stroke is this he's had health problems
since the campaign's real since he had a
major stroke that even the New York
Times reports has rendered him unable to
process a lot of language he has
difficulty speaking he has difficulty
understanding words especially when he's
stressed and being a senator is a
stressful job
it's good that he's getting help it's
good that he's he's saying I can't take
this right now and he's you know a lot
better than the alternative but
Democrats need to let this poor man go
home okay the Democrat argument was even
if he's a stroke victim even if he he
doesn't have a functioning brain at the
moment he needs to recover we're going
to send him to Washington because it
doesn't matter you don't need to have a
functioning brain to be a senator and
frankly you really don't because the the
point of these Senators very often is
just to rubber stamp whatever leadership
wants them to do that was the campaign
pitch for this guy so okay fine if
that's what they want to do that's what
they want to do it's the same argument
for Joe Biden Joe Biden might not know
what end is up but it's fine he'll just
go along with whatever the Democrat
establishment wants
let the poor man go home this is
obviously ruining his life
and this is not some random clinical
thing what you're going to hear is the
same nonsense that you're hearing about
the kids who are depressed and suicidal
saying oh this is just clinical it's
clinical depression no you know what we
just need to prescribe them more
Pharmaceuticals yeah that's it we'll
just give them more drugs and apply them
to be numb and that's really the problem
no the depression is a symbol and a
symptom of a deeper problem John
Federman has a lot of reason to be down
in the dumps
he does he's being used by his
probably his family certainly by his
political party
he's he's being put in a terrible spot
he's he is genuinely frustrated because
he's lost a lot of his abilities the
abilities that he once had and he's not
being allowed to get the help that he
needs yeah I'd be pretty down in the
dumps too
the way to fix that is not just apply
the guy with more drugs the way to fix
that is to change the behavior change
the society change the ritual change the
way that we're all interacting with one
another same thing goes for the kids
same thing goes for all of us these are
structural problems which until we until
we fix those until we even acknowledge
that those exist
we're just going to keep sliding in the
same direction
no question about it I want to talk
about depressing things the cost of eggs
has surpassed the price
of beef eggs are more expensive than
beef right now
we'll get into that more next week but
that's an amazing statistic
makes us feel like we're becoming a
third world country our trains don't run
we've got poison seeping out everywhere
we can't afford food people are
depressed the average life expectancy is
decreasing
because of deaths of Despair we don't
have a functioning border whatever we
are doing right now we always want to
project our power overseas and say we're
going to solve all the world's problems
and we need to go spread democracy
around the world or whatever how about
we how about we spread a flourishing
Society here at home
We are Becoming like a third world
country
till we get that in check it's going to
be very hard to help the rest of the
world this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select to
plan enter code nulls Canada wels you
get 50 off your first month take it away
with the first voicemail bag question
Dear Mr Knowles my name is Noah meshack
23 years old I've watched every show of
yours for the last nine months and
haven't heard a question quite like this
after dating my now ex-wife for four
years while in the Marine Corps we
decided to get married about six months
before the end of my contract
one month after getting married she
began having an affair
after buying a house together a year and
a half of marriage counseling and some
time being separated she still continued
to see him
after all of that I decided to divorce
her
it was the hardest decision of my entire
life but I couldn't let the woman I
wanted to spend the rest of my life with
continuously break our vows and our vows
to God as well as my heart
I would like to see what you think about
this as I hold your opinion with the
utmost respect and I hope to see you on
the campaign Trail someday thanks Mr
Knowles
pal I am sorry to hear about those
problems that is really really tough one
thank you for your service two thanks
for listening to the show for this long
and three really sorry to hear what you
were going through
the first thing that I would do if I
were in your position
well I would do exactly what you did I
think you did the right thing you tried
to get marriage counseling you tried to
forgive your wife you gave her the
opportunity to correct her behavior she
still wouldn't do it
so what do you do the conflict here is
that
many Christians certainly Catholics but
some other other shades of protestant as
well uh believe that marriage is
indissoluble
so it's not can you get divorced you
have a right to get divorced it's it's a
denial of the ontological possibility of
divorce that what God has joined let no
man separate
so
there is one method available
uh if you hold to that view
which is annulment
an annulment is not
an investigation into
things that have happened after the
marriage took place you know why did she
have this affair who is this guy or it's
it's a question about was the marriage
valid in the first place and I don't
know I just don't know enough about your
situation uh to say one way or the other
it would seem if your wife
so quickly
started this affair so quickly
and persistently engaged in these
behaviors I wouldn't be surprised let's
say if she was keeping certain things
from you before the marriage
I would not be surprised at all if that
were the case
probably there is a good argument to be
made that the marriage was not valid in
the first place again I don't know this
is above my pay grade you you would if
you're if you're Catholic or if you're a
member of an ecclesial community that
that uh
views things this way you would want to
have an annulment investigation to to
check that out in which case it wasn't a
real marriage you go on maybe get
remarried or something like that some
people
uh believe that adultery is is actually
a justification for formal divorce not a
an annulment but a divorce they they
have come up with this idea in the
recent centuries based on what they view
to be the acceptive clause in the gospel
of Matthew that uh
uh no man can separate what God has
joined except for pornea is the word
which is often translated as whorishness
or adultery or something like that uh
that this is not the traditional
interpretation of that line the idea of
the acceptive Clause is a relatively
novel in Christianity so I I wouldn't
hang your hat on that if if you do
happen to be a Christian
uh what what I would see here though in
any case is some spiritual guidance you
you did the you did the
thing that we're all supposed to do
which is marriage counseling if one
finds oneself in this situation uh but
but now your problems are
almost purely uh spiritual what what do
you do now and so that that is my view
That's my kind of truncated version of
my view of where you go from here and
what the situation looks like uh but I
would I would pursue more expert uh
spiritual advice and uh we can all pray
for you in the meantime really really
tough situation that you're in and uh I
guess you know as all suffering is
an opportunity to be Sanctified although
one is very often not happy for the
opportunity to be Sanctified in
suffering uh while one is going through
it but that is a you know a Central
Christian ideas that our suffering binds
us to the uh to the suffering of Our
Lord on the cross I mean the Saint Paul
writes about this quite clearly and this
is this is the traditional understanding
though it's sometimes easier to to view
it in the rear view mirror than it is
while you're going through it next
question
hey Michael Matt here in Des Moines Iowa
calling uh I'm a small business owner
but uh more importantly than that I am a
believer in Christ as well as a husband
and a father I have a very strong desire
to be involved in local Politics on the
city level the county level be it school
board meetings standing up and then
speaking what's right and true
but I do have a fear that doing so could
negatively affect my business I work in
a very liberal industry I've seen others
be blacklisted for doing what's right
and I have employees so I'm worried that
if I stand up and say something
whether it's true or not I could be
negatively affected my my ability to
provide for my family would be affected
and the ability of my employees to
provide for their families be affected
so I'm wondering if you give us some
advice on when to do that when do you
stand up is there a good way to do that
that could uh
mitigate those effects or is it just
on or off throw caution to the wind and
say the thing and deal with the
consequences later
thanks for your time Michael God bless
you have a great one
the first thing you have to recognize is
that business is political
in recent decades there have been some
libertarian slogeneers who have tried to
suggest that business is not political
that politics is just for the
politicians and the government but
business the private sector that's not
really political but it is political
because political just means public
politics just refers to public life it's
how we all get along together it's much
more intricate it's much more intricate
and it's it's much more complex than
just uh you know a senator and a
congressman and going to The Ballot Box
on Tuesday
it's politics is all of public life and
frankly
The Way businesses operate the way that
zoning is done in your town the way that
schools are established the way that
neighbor interacts with neighbor
that constitutes much more of politics
than what some Congressman says at a
press conference so
I think you need to recognize that you
are in politics already
and even the illusion that some
businesses were not political was simply
that it was an illusion businesses
certainly had standards that they had to
observe they had an ideology that they
were following even during the height of
what we might call the liberal consensus
in the middle to the to the
slightly post-middle part of the 20th
century
so you're already there and therefore if
you're engaging in politics you have to
be prudent
you need to articulate your convictions
do the right thing don't do things that
are immoral and unjust but within
Prudential limits because politics
exists in reality with real people and
it it applies Eternal principles to
changing circumstances so I would
recommend in these questions as ever
Prudence don't lie about what you
believe don't compromise on the things
that you hold most dear but you you
don't need to be flamboyant about it
either you don't need to wear a Maga hat
behind the cash register every single
day we're called to be wise as serpents
and innocent as dubs next question
hi Michael my name is Caitlin and I've
really enjoyed listening to your show
for the past two years I first
discovered you when I stumbled upon the
Wall Street Betsy Shanty video on
YouTube and since then I've been hooked
so I have a question for you today I am
the worship leader at my church and I
recently discovered that there are at
least five guys in our church who are
involved in Freemasonry and that's a
little bit concerning because of the
research I've been doing I've kind of
discovered that it has some satanic
roots and that the further up you get in
the organization the more they tell you
that actually it's Satan you're
worshiping and not God like they say at
the beginning when you're initiated
anyway I'm just kind of concerned about
my congregation because I don't want
these guys to like start recruiting
other people and you know people to be
led astray especially as the worship
leader I feel a sense of responsibility
so do you have any thoughts on anything
I can do or thoughts on Freemasonry I'd
love to hear your opinion thank you so
much
certainly I don't know anything they
tell you about Satan in the highest
levels of Freemasonry I'm not a Mason
myself so I don't know about that I've
certainly heard rumors we've all heard
rumors like that but I would say even
putting that aside for a second because
I I just don't know the the reality of
that
at a really basic level the problem with
Freemasonry and why a Christian really
can't be a Freemason is that it is a
kind of a rival religion
it has all of the aspects of a religion
it has its own initiation rituals its
own burial rituals its own altar its own
its own garments its own uh it has even
its own higher beliefs in as much as it
makes a a kind of religion out of
naturalism and rationalism this is why
it crops up
during the Enlightenment this is why the
first enemy of Freemasonry was the
Catholic Church you know it was
established again I know Freemasonry has
changed over the centuries but an
objective a major objective of
Freemasonry in the earliest days was was
to dismantle the Catholic Church which
it viewed as a kind of
Supernatural and tyrannical body
and it was going to following the the
doctrines of the Enlightenment it was
going to bring about this new kind of
religious view based on naturalism and
rationalism it also posits
indifferentism which is the idea that it
doesn't matter what formal religion you
adhere to you know that all of those can
be equally pleasing to God and and so
plenty of people believe those ideas
that's why I'm not really knocking the
Freemasons in particular lots of people
believe those ideas today but those
ideas are not compatible with anything
even slightly resembling an orthodox
understanding of Christianity so that
would be the problem you know I don't
think you need to go to the the idea
that your buddies who essentially joined
a fraternity and you know I mean I know
people who have been involved in
Freemasonry and that you know they think
it's just like a fun thing to do and
it's a fraternity and it's you know no
big deal
um so I I you know I don't think you
need to impugn their motives or you know
I think that they're intentionally
worshiping the devil or anything like
that but you just you just might point
out that when we participate in certain
rituals and in certain organizations and
we we sign off on certain Creeds and
certain dogmas
sometimes those can contradict other
Creeds and dogmas that we have ascended
to and when those two things are in
Conflict well you you have to pick one
if you want to be consistent you don't
want to violate the law of
non-contradiction and so you got to pick
one and if you got to pick one I guess
you would probably agree with me that I
would I would recommend the church but
it's a modern world so many people don't
make that choice we've got more
voicemail back we've got more written
mailbag and we've got fake headline
Friday
all ready to go
the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss a go to
dailywear.com Knowles use code Knowles
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]